I really don't like to get into my office on,
on [inaudible].
And the reason is I just don't feel like it's my job.
I feel like it's your job.
My job is different,
you know,
my job is to go up there and just,
make them laugh,
but I don't want to be divisive.
Yeah.
I hear,
Ya know,
I just don't want to do it because it's,
my fan base is split and you know,
I've had,
uh,
and,
and you know,
nothing ever really happens,
but I,
I had a guy one time because I said something to meet and greet who is paid to
take a picture of me and then refused to take a picture of me because of what I
said.
And I'm like,
I don't give a fuck dude.
Don't take a picture.
Leave that.
I don't give a shit really touching.
Yeah.
But you know,
that's also one of the,
it's like they're exerting power over you.
I'm not even take a picture.
I'm going to unfollow you on Instagram to run white.
Right.
God Damn Communist.
Yeah.
What am I going to do?
Told the one girl,
she said,
now I'm going to own file.
You used to be funny,
but now you're just doing it and I'm going to unfollow you and I know it doesn't
matter.
And I said,
you can't leave.
All the plants will die
whenever you're in a in a bind quote Bill Murray.
Yeah.
People are just so mean.
It's wanting to hurt you.
Ron White for no reason.
Yeah,
but nobody,
I've already been as mad as I can be and I'll never be mad or in.
It happened when I was 16 years old,
so it's hard to make me mad and I'll tell you what made me mad.
I just got my driver's license.
My mother asked me to go to the store to get something.
It's in the summer and he Euston.
I don't have any shoes on.
Oh my door step into a shitty pampers that somebody had just thrown in the
parking lot and it and I didn't just put a toe in and go,
oh,
that's baby shit.
That's wrong.
I just showed my whole foot into it.
Green baby shit coming through my toes,
smears all over the diaper.
Right.
So I'm stuck.
I don't know what to do.
I'm not going to get back in my mother's car with the shitty food.
I can't go into the store with baby shit all over my foot.
And I thought about just cutting my foot off and just leave it in the diaper
with a note that said,
you should used to be a perfectly good fucking foot dude.
And nobody's ever made me that mad since I was so fucking furious.
And I just wanted to hate and kill and over a shitty pamper.
That's crazy that that was all it took.
That's all it took.
But it was so,
you know,
it just put me in a,
I've been stuck before.
Let me tell you about the other time I was stuck.
This will get us off of politics.
Um,
I'm in my tour bus and,
uh,
I'm party when my buddy Steve and my best friend,
my road manager who passed away and,
and he never gets laid,
but it looked like he had an angle on this girl.
So I picked up my beer and went back to my bedroom,
which I never do.
I sit up there and drink with the guys and I go back there to just to go to
sleep.
But I'd never take booze back there or anything in it.
But I,
I'd gone back there and lay down and I put that a Doseck he's bottle on the
counter and then we took off during the night while I was real drunk and Steve
and real drunk in the bottle falls off and breaks and I don't hear it.
So in the middle of the night and my bed sits high cause you want to try to get
those beds towards them,
center the cause.
It's on those axles anyway.
But the closer it is to the center,
the better fields when you're in it.
So you kind of slacked off of it about an inch.
And I have my foot went into,
uh,
the bottom of the beer bottle at a shard hanging off of it,
about an inch and a half long.
And uh,
and I just,
and I landed on it.
Well now I know exactly what it was and uh,
and somebody had hit the master lights so I can't turn the lights on.
You have to go back and turn them out on the master switch.
But I know that around me is broken glass everywhere because I understand what
happened.
I understand that bottle fell broke and I got it in my foot.
So I pull him up foot up and I didn't know how big the Shard was and I just pull
it out of their blood.
Just starts gushing out was Steve's passed out in a bunk and he can't hear me.
I can't get to a phone.
I can't see.
So what do I do?
I just crawled back in bed and went to sleep and bled and uh,
and Steve said the next morning it looked like somebody killed a hog in there
and,
and uh,
he is lifted up the sheets.
Even the bus driver saw my foot and they were like,
I just,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
Did you worry about bleeding out?
I didn't know what else to do cause they're,
the only option was to take another step and cut the other foot.
And,
uh,
do you have your phone with you?
I wasn't within reach.
I was just stuck and,
and I was also drunk,
stuck in drunk it bleeding.
Damn.
That's a good combination.
Yeah.
I was stumped.
I didn't know what to do.
I don't know how to fucking combat,
so I would just crawl back in bed and I'm like,
well,
is your foot oh,
13 stitches.
Uh,
as soon as I woke up and looked at him,
let's go to the hospital guys.
And uh,
things sewed it back up,
13 on the bottom of my foot,
right in the arch.
And uh,
it was,
uh,
you know,
it was,
it was a mess.
It was a fucking mess.
Every time if you fuck your foot up,
you realize how much you need them.
Like you could fuck your shoulder up and that sucks,
but you can still walk somewhere and get something with your other foot up.
You're like,
oh,
okay,
this is,
this is a real problem
operation or something.